unis ce jeudi matin dans le hall de la
clinique les salariés peine encore à
digérer la nouvelle
leurs établissements risquent de fermer
ses portes et l'annoncé a été brutale
la direction nous a convoqué l'ensemble
du personnel et nous a informés que il
met déposé le bilan et qui nous mettait
en liquidation judiciaire
une décision du groupe kapa santé
précipitée par la suspension du service
de chirurgie décidée mardi par la rs
lagence met en avant des
dysfonctionnements un manque de
personnel des travaux non réalisés pour
l'équipe médicale le dossier est géré
des deux côtés au détriment des patients
on est pris en otage en fin des conflits
entre la rs et le groupe k passé pour
moi à mon sens c'est mon sentiment mais
il ya un acharnement de la rs sur nous
et le groupe kapa
qui effectivement donne aussi des bâtons
prospère date parce qu'ils ne font pas
toujours d investissement en temps et en
heure mais on sent bien que dans tous
les contrôles qu on a ce sont des
contrôles à charge
nous avons essayé à plusieurs reprises
d'obtenir des explications de la
direction du groupe et de la clinique
sans réponse de leur part si la
liquidation est maintenue caunes risque
de perdre ses urgences et son service de
radiologie après la maternité il y a
deux ans une perspective qui inquiète
les passions c'est cette dramatique pour
la population des environs comme s'il
fallait le faire ou un chien à chaud à
bourges pour le montre la moindre chose
de toute façon ici il n'y a que ça donc
c'était l'endroit où on est pour se
faire soigner mais en ville si la
décision indigne de la population les
habitants questionne la gestion de
l'établissement
le groupe kapa a déjà fermés ou vendus
plusieurs de ces cliniques ces dernières
années et certains se demandent s'il y
avait une réelle volonté de conserver le
site de caunes
ça a été repris plusieurs fois après bon
voilà c'est comme tout je pense qu'il
faut que ce soit la médecine doit
devenir rentable sauf que c'est tout
sauf rentables plutôt à vocation humaine
à la base une manifestation est déjà
prévue samedi pour faire entendre
l'inquiétude du personnel soignant et
des caunois
pas question pour eux de voir leurs
cliniques fermé sans se battre